مولود كل خمسه عشره ثانيه يولد في مصر اي
ان عدد الولادات في الدقيقه يصل الى حوالي
اربعه ما شاء الله ما شاء الله عدد سكان
مصر مشاهدينا يقفز الى 105 ملايين سنه
وفقا للساعه السكانيه التي تتابع من
خلالها السلطات المصريه عدد السكان بالضبط
تحققت هذه الزياده نتيجه الفرق بين اعداد
المواليد والوفيات
وهذا الفرق هو مليون نسمه خلال ثمانيه
اشهر وخمسه ايام طبعا مستويات الانجاب في
مصر
ما زرت
يؤدي الى زياده عدد سكانها الى 165 مليون
نسمه بحلول عام 2050 بحسب هذا التقرير
الله يزيد ويبارك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات